[Music]
cardi B makes a surprise appearance at
the American Music Awards joining
glorilla on stage for a performance of
their hit tomorrow too
has the crowd on their feet as she rocks
the stage
to keep s her today
I love her you know a whole lot a whole
lot of hood
that's a good person to have in your
corner yeah I love her I can say this
this family right there
Cardi's moment comes after the show's
touching tribute for her husband
offset's cousin the late takeoff we
recently just lost Kirsten Nick Kari
ball better known as takeoff Wayne Brady
host of the amas takes a moment to
recognize his impact on the music world
on behalf of all of us that love hip-hop
and music all around the world we thank
you take off for your Artistry and
tonight we honor your memory Stars at
the event are reflecting on the loss of
takeoff too including Tinashe who
praised the Migos rapper and the Legacy
he left behind you know I think takeoff
was such an amazing talent and I think
he's going to go down in history as
somebody who really set the Mark I think
the Migos was such a legendary group and
I'm just honestly
still very very very very sad about the
entire how it all played out and I think
that we're
you know we're really missing one of our
generational figures I think that he
went way too soon 28 so young so it's
definitely a tragedy and I think you
know his music is going to go down in
history on the test of time big fan
[Music]
thank you